hey this is prasha walker
this problem was shared on facebook with
the claim that only one in a thousand
people could figure it out
it soon generated controversy
and it now has over 3 million comments
in this video i'm going to present what
many people believe to be the correct
answer
can you figure it out
give it a try before watching the video
so most people agree that the answer
should be 96.
the pattern in each line is to take the
first number
and add it to the product of the first
and the second number
so for example the first line is one
plus four
so we should interpret one plus four as
one plus one times four
this will be equal to five
the second line which is two plus five
should be interpreted as two plus two
times five
two times five is ten
and adding two gets us to the result of
twelve
the third line of three plus six should
be interpreted as three plus three times
six
and that is equal to twenty
this means the final line of eight plus
11 should be interpreted as eight plus
eight times eleven
eight times eleven is eighty-eight and
adding eight gets us to the answer of
ninety-six
there were people however who disagreed
with this interpretation
they believed the answer should have
been a different number
which is
40. how did they arrive at this answer
they thought the puzzle should be
interpreted as a running total where you
add up the numbers from each line
so the first line of 1 plus 4 equals 5
is a correct mathematical result
in the next line where you have 2 plus 5
you should preface that by adding the
result of 5 from the previous line
when we add 5 to 2 plus 5 we get the
answer of 12
and that matches what's given in the
original problem
we now add 12 to 3 plus 6 and that gets
us to 21.
this interpretation is consistent with
the information that we're giving
if we continue the pattern we then take
21 and add that to 8 plus 11 and that
gets to the other answer of 40.
so many people were debating whether the
answer should be 96 or whether it should
be 40.
there is a way to reconcile these two
approaches
and we can see that the answer of 96 can
be justified under the running total
method
so let's see how that's possible
so when we have this running total of
the different numbers in each line
notice that the first numbers we're
adding are 1 and then 2 and then 3.
if we continue this pattern
we might think that the next number we
should be adding should be four
what about the second number
well we have four plus five plus six
logic would suggest that the next number
should be seven
so the next line should be four plus
seven now this is not part of our
original puzzle but if we were to
continue the pattern from the original
puzzle we have this extra missing line
that could be placed in there
so now what happens if we take our
previous total of 21 and add it to four
plus seven
we get the answer of 32
what would be the next line
well we'd want to increase four by one
to get five and we want to increase
seven by one to get eight
so the next line would be five plus
eight
we therefore take 32 plus 5 plus 8 and
that gets us to 45
we continue the pattern
the next line should be 6 plus 9.
we add that to our previous result to 45
we get 60
then we have 7 plus 10 we add that to 60
to get 77
and when we continue the pattern we once
again get to 8 plus 11 and we want to
add our previous result of 77
and then we get the answer of 96
so under this interpretation we also get
to the answer of 96.
we only need to adjust the running total
by putting in some of these missing
lines that are not part of the original
puzzle
but they make sense if we were to
increase the first number and the second
number in each line
so under this interpretation of the
running total we also get that the
answer is 96
therefore it seems very likely that the
answer to this puzzle
should be 96 because under either
interpretation we get to this result
what do you think did you get to 96
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description